Alright I'm sold. You want to make an approval process.
What are we going to do? Help me out here.
>> Well before we jump to make the approval process we need
to think about what are we actually trying to create the flow for.
>> Okay.
>> So we have our stage managers.
>> Yeah.
>> And they need to approve whether or
not bands can be book at certain set times.
>> Okay.
>> So we want to create an approval process on set times.
>> Set times, makes sense. And when a booking agent tries
to book something, the stage manager has to sign off.
>> Exactly.
>> Cool. Okay. So, I guess I'll just search for approvals or something.
>> Yep. It's in the set up.
>> Okay. Okay. Workflow and approvals,
cool. Approval process. It's recommended that
I follow the following instructions. I'm not going to do it though. So.
>> Rules are meant to be broken.
>> Yeah. Manage approval processes for set time right?
>> Exactly.
>> Okay, create new.
>> Yep. Click that guy.
>> Ooh, I have a choice of wizards, a jump start
wizard, or a standard set up. Do you have a preference?
>> I use jump start, it's quicker.
>> Okay. Okay, name for the approval process? Stage Manager Sign Off?
>> Yeah sure. Stage manager approval, whatever.
>> Approval oh yeah they're called approvals.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> So approval assignment email template. What are we
doing with that? Are we even setting an email?
>> So we could if we wanted to, but we don't have to so in this case it's
okay. Okay, so we've got our specific entry criteria,
use this approval process if defined criteria are met.
>> So this is really similar to the workflow rule,
right, where we're trying to come up with some certain criteria.
>> Uh-huh.
>> That this should only fire this process if.
>> Something
happens, it's true.
>> If there's a baseline.
>> Okay.
>> And so when would we not want it to go for approval? Like, when would
we be like, this is bad data. This
shouldn't be under approval, because it's not complete.
>> There wasn't a, a field miss, there's a field missing?
>> Exactly. And so, what's the most important field on set time that would,
has to be there, in order for it to be something we should review?